hello everybody this is Gary Vaynerchuk
and this is my 120 you know I was
driving to work today at the wine Lib
and I was thinking about why I was so
fortunate to have a such a great life
and be so happy and what was making that
happen why I was like 99% happy all the
time and I was really trying to you know
give it some thought and I'm looking for
something to play with and I came to a
conclusion that it comes down to the BPP
which is my big-picture patch listen
I've got a lot of stresses and a lot of
things going on in my life like anybody
else we all have headaches and there's
so many things going on in the world and
so many things to worry about
and I think a lot of its genetics and
obviously probably at the end of the day
the biggest factor in my overall
happiness in life has to come down to my
parents my mother is I mean is he a
saint is she a saint I mean she may be
even bigger what's what's better than a
saint I mean she is legitimately the
greatest human being on earth BarNone my
brother and my sister and my wife I have
so many great things going for me
however there's always pressures and
running a big business like I have
there's something going on every minute
and I was trying to think about what
really differentiates me from all the
other people I kind of know in my life
which is that um 99% happy I'm just
happy all the time pretty much every day
all the time
happiness and so it really came down to
me that it came down to the BBP and the
BPP is my big picture patch I think it
works both ways
even at the height of happiness or the
low of depression the BPP is a great
thing and bpp is a black black a big
picture patch and what that means is
that no matter what's going on you
always have to look at the big picture
in the big picture is the health and
happiness of the closest five to ten
people in your life and I have that and
no matter being on television or being
really sad when I think about that
that's all I really care about and by
only caring about the big picture it
helps me to live my life